Olá pessoal Será que aveia realmente faz
bem para todo mundo aqui é o Dr Alan
Dutra e hoje eu trago algumas
considerações importantes sobre aveia eu
vou compartilhar com vocês seus
principais benefícios também Vamos
explorar os diferentes tipos desse grão
vamos também discutir os antinutrientes
que estão presentes e falar um pouco
sobre a venina uma proteína presente na
veia e que pode ser inflamatória para
muitos também não vou deixar de Fora as
melhores formas de consumir aveia para
aproveitar ao máximo seus benefícios sei
que ao tocar nesse assunto de aveia
posso estar mexendo em algo quase
sagrado para muitos aveia claro que é
saudável muitos dirão com aquela certeza
passada de geração para geração afinal
se a nossa avó comia aveia todos os dias
está mais ativa que muitos de nós como
poderia iia ser diferente não é mesmo
Mas será que a história é bem assim para
mim pessoalmente apesar de gostar muito
do Sabor da veia ela não me faz bem ela
solta o meu intestino os que me
acompanham sabem das dificuldades que eu
enfrentei com problemas intestinais e
enxaquecas severas no passado que só
começaram a melhorar quando eu me voltei
para práticas mais naturais de saúde e
também passei a prestar mais atenção ao
que eu comia agora especialmente se você
se identifica com alguns dos grupos que
eu vou mencionar como pessoas com
doenças autoimunes com problemas
intestinais
frequentes diabetes ou que enfrentam
deficiência de minerais e nutrientes
esta informação é crucial para todos mas
se você faz parte desses grupos eu peço
que fique comigo até o final desse vídeo
não deixe assistir na íntegra
Mas vamos nos focar primeiro nos
benefícios da aveia começando pelo
farelo de aveia que é a camada externa
do grão da aveia ele é rico em fibras
especialmente as betaglucan que são
ótimas pro coração e pra digestão a
betaglucana estimula o sistema
digestório contribuindo para uma
digestão mais eficiente ela é indicada
para melhorar a saúde do coração porque
ajuda a equilibrar os níveis de
colesterol e triglicerídeos no organismo
já os flocos de aveia obtidos ao prensar
os grãos inteiros conservam bons
nutrientes e fibras já a farinha de
aveia é simplesmente aveia moída até
virar pó Essa é a menos recomendada
porque perde mais nutrientes e fibras
nesse processo pessoal no geral a veia
contém além das fibras antioxidantes e
micronutrientes como manganês selênio
fósforo ferro zinco e magnésio Porém tem
um probleminha nisso que eu vou explicar
melhor daqui a pouco se você incluir
aveia na sua rotina você pode ver
benefícios na sua pele devido a sua
composição rica em magnésio cobre e
Zinco a veia pode auxiliar na produção
de colágeno potencialmente melhorando A
firmeza e aparência da pele Além disso O
manganês pode ajudar a reduzir o inchaço
e a inflamação da pele enquanto an
antioxidante exclusivo encontrado na
veia que a avenant tram oferece
propriedades antiinflamatórias e
calmantes para irritações cutâneas a
venant tram também pode ajudar a
melhorar a saúde cardiovascular
dilatando as artérias e melhorando o
fluxo sanguíneo O que pode contribuir
para a redução da pressão arterial a
aveia também é rica em fibras solúveis e
insolúveis que podde ajudar na limpeza
do corpo e na promoção de o sistema
sistema digestório saudável esse
alimento pode ser particularmente útil
para melhorar a regularidade intestinal
a veia não só alivia a constipação mas
também nutre Nossa microbiota intestinal
garantindo o sistema digestório saudável
e feliz Imagine se eu te dissesse que a
veia pode reduzir o seu risco de
desenvolver câncer de intestino estudos
mostraram que a fibra da aveia pode
diminuir esse risco em até 10% para cada
10 g adicionados à sua dieta diária e
para aqueles que estão lutando contra a
balança a veia pode ser uma aliada
surpreendente com seu alto teor de
fibras e proteínas ela ajuda a aumentar
a saciedade e a controlar o peso Claro
com moderação e junto com uma dieta
equilibrada bom pessoal já deu para ver
que ela possui muitos benefícios certo
mas e quanto ao diabetes e o açúcar do
sangue Pesquisas mostram que a veia Pode
ser sim uma aliada para quem busca
melhorar o controle do açúcar no sangue
uma revisão de 16 estudos realizada em
2015 revelou que a veia ajudou a reduzir
tanto o açúcar no sangue em jejum quanto
os níveis de hemoglobina glicada a
chamada hemoglobina a1c se você não está
familiarizado a hemoglobina glicada é um
indicador do controle do a aar no sangue
a longo prazo O que significa que a veia
pode ajudar não apenas momentaneamente
mas manter os níveis de açúcar no sangue
estáveis ao longo do tempo já uma
revisão sistemática e metanálise
publicada em 2021 na revista nutrients
concluiu que consumir aveia regularmente
pode estar associado ao menor risco de
desenvolver o diabetes tipo 2 além de
contribuir pra saúde cardiovascular e
até mesmo reduzir a mortalidade por
todas as causas isso é impressionante
considerando que estamos falando de um
alimento simples e acessível mas nesse
estudo a conclusão é limitada e
baseia-se principalmente em dados
observacionais tornando difícil tirar
conclusões firmes vamos agora às partes
polêmicas pessoal não se enganem em
geral eu sou sim a favor da veia mas é
crucial entender vermos o contexto maior
e as nuances que envolvem o seu consumo
muitos aem como um ingrediente mágico um
Elixir de saúde eterna Quanto mais
melhor dizem mas será que podemos
generalizar assim se o seu café da manhã
se resume a um pãozinho francês com
geleia torradas com margarina Ou aquele
cereal de milho açucarado da caixinha
substituí-los por uma tigela de ave com
fruta certamente é um grande upgrade uma
melhora significativa e eu apoio isso
com certeza no entanto o que eu quero
que vocês entendam é que a resposta para
si a aveia é saudável Depende muito do
contexto e da individualidade de cada um
ah a individualidade complicando tudo né
Essa palavra tão recorrente em nossas
discussões sobre alimentação e é verdade
não existe uma resposta única que sirva
para todos isso complica até passar
informações para vocês nas redes sociais
e no YouTube e sabe por as necessidades
e reações ao consumo de certos alimentos
variam incrivelmente de pessoa para
pessoa isso se tornou ainda mais
Evidente com o passar dos anos a mistura
das etnias a globalização de alimentos
as modificações genéticas e os
agrotóxicos nos alimentos e
principalmente com as mudanças na
qualidade da nossa alimentação em geral
peguemos o exemplo da nossa vó
Centenária robusta e saudável que
cresceu comendo aveia o contexto dela
era outro uma alimentação bem mais
natural em sua juventude Ela comeu mais
comida de verdade menos agrotóxicos
menos alimentos modificados e menos
industrializados um sistema de defesa
imune mais forte e um intestino mais
saudável além de um estilo de vida
Possivelmente mais ativo e um contato
mais próximo com a natureza e com muito
menos estress hoje enfrentamos desafios
diferentes e nosso sistema de defesa
imune reage de maneira distinta portanto
antes de coroarmos a veia como a rainha
indiscutível da Saúde precisamos olhar
pro quadro completo considerando as
peculiaridades de cada um de nós Você já
parou para pensar que cada grão de aveia
é na verdade uma pequena semente pronta
para dar vida a uma nova planta é
fascinante não é mesmo mas aqui vai uma
curiosidade que talvez você não saiba
essas sementes tão cheias de vida
carregam algo chamado antinutrientes
Imagine só as plantas não podem fugir de
seus predadores certo elas não têm
pernas para correr nem dentes para se
defender ou garras para poder se
defender então a natureza sendo a mestra
que é dotou as sementes de algo especial
para protegê-las os antinutrientes é
essas substâncias são como escudo é como
se a planta dissesse se você me comer
não vai tirar muita vantagem daqui e vai
até passar mal agora você deve estar
pensando bom eu estou comendo aveia
cheia de minerais Mas será que eu estou
aproveitando tudo isso pois é os
antinutrientes podem ser um obstáculo
nessa história aveia contém em especial
dois antinutrientes um deles é o fitato
ou ácido fítico
que é um bloqueador de minerais ele é
uma substância presente em todos os
grãos e sementes e compõe de 1 a 7% do
peso total da semente essa substância
tem a propriedade de grudar nos
nutrientes minerais como se fosse um ímã
mesmo e com isso vai evitar a absorção
desses minerais pelo organismo fazendo
com que a gente não receba esses
minerais importantes como é o caso do
cálcio magnésio Ferro C zinco e assim
por diante portanto pessoal se você está
enfrentando uma dificuldade na absorção
de minerais por exemplo de um ferro
baixo que é mais comum você deve ter
atenção especial ao consumo de aveia
além do fitato temos também as lectinas
que são proteínas produzidas pelas
plantas também como mecanismo de defesa
para poder impedir que as suas sementes
sejam comidas por pragas por insetos e
também para proteger contra micror
organismos como mofo e fungos quando as
lectinas são ingeridas elas irritam
trato digestório causando desconforto na
pessoa ou no animal que comeu a planta
porque a ideia é que o Predador aprenda
a não comer mais aquela semente a
lectina mais famosa que a gente conhece
é o glúten pessoal o glúten é uma
lectina embora na teoria aveia não
contenha glúten eu já explico isso
melhor as lectinas com idas na veia
provocam reações muito parecidas com
glúten no que se refere a inflamação da
parede do intestino e na causa da
hiperpermeabilidade intestinal o liqu
Gut o intestino que vaza e a gente sabe
que esses danos do intestino é a porta
de entrada para muitas doenças inclusive
doenças autoimunes Mas calma Nem tudo
está perdido os nossos ancestrais com a
sua sabedoria sabiam lidar com esses
antin nutrientes Como deixar os grãos de
molho cozinhar fermentar Ou esperar que
germinassem antes de consumir reduzindo
assim os seus efeitos e hoje em dia bem
parece que nós esquecemos dessas
técnicas antigas não é mesmo vamos tirar
do saquinho e pronto mas o segredo para
aproveitar todos os benefícios da aveia
sem os inconvenientes dos antinutrientes
está justamente em resgatar essas
práticas simples de preparo primeira
dica Deixe os flocos grossos ou farelo
de aveia de molho por 12 horas isso
ajuda a diminuir os antinutrientes que
atrapalham a absorção de minerais
lembre-se de jogar fora a água usada Ok
se você curte o mingal melhor o
cozimento ajuda a reduzir parte desses
antinutrientes e é uma excelente escolha
além de gostoso facilita a absorção dos
nutrientes mas não vale jogar um monte
de Açúcar agora uma dica de ouro
fermentar a aveia para fazer iogurte
além de reduzir os antinutrientes você
ganha probióticos benéficos misture com
frutas e terá um lanche nutritivo e
delicioso tem receitas diversas na
internet pessoal ah essa é uma pergunta
que muita gente faz a aveia contém
glúten Vamos lá por natureza a aveia não
contém glúten no entanto A questão aqui
é que durante o processo de cultivo
transporte ou mesmo processamento a veia
pode acabar se misturando com trigo
cevado ou centeio Que são fontes de
glúten Isso significa que a menos que a
veia seja especialmente processada para
evitar a contaminação cruzada e rotulada
como sem glúten ela pode sim conter
traços de glúten então se você tem
doença celíaca é Sens
ou alérgico ao glúten vai precisar
procurar por aveia que Garanta ser livre
de contaminação cruzada Ok então vamos
lá vamos continuar com mais polêmica
pessoal embora a veia não seja tão
inflamatória quanto o glúten ela pode de
fato ser problemática para algumas
pessoas assim como no meu caso você já
ouviu falar na Avenina é uma proteína
que encontramos na veia bem parecida com
o famoso glúten do Trigo ambas são da
família das prolaminas e podem ter
efeitos semelhantes no nosso corpo ou
seja podem ser sim inflamatórias ao
longo dos anos tanto o trigo quanto a
veia passaram por mudanças o trigo por
exemplo passou por melhoramento genético
e teve um aumento absurdo Na quantidade
de glúten uma adaptação para melhorar a
Panificação e a elasticidade da massa
isso claro trouxe algumas complicações
pra nossa saúde mais inflamação doenças
intestinais doenças autoimunes e
alergias então e a veia bem ela também
teve os seus ajustes mais de uma maneira
que Manteve a Avenina um pouco mais
amigável digamos assim agora vamos ao
que interessa mesmo sendo menos
agressiva a venina ainda pode ser uma
dor de cabeça para quem tem certa
sensibilidade ou condições de saúde ela
pode por exemplo contribuir para
hiperpermeabilidade intestinal que
aquele problema que a parede do
intestino fica danificada e partículas
não digeridas de alimentos acabam
passando pela parede do intestino indo
parar na corrente sanguínea isso vai
desencadear todo tipo de reações
inclusive doenças autoimunes para
pessoas com doenças autoimunes disbiose
intestino hiper permeável
diagnosticado ou ainda cibo que é o
sobre crescimento bacteriano do
intestino delgado É sim aconselhável ter
cautela ao consumir aveia devido à
presença não só da venina como também
dos antinutrientes mas olha pessoal é
sempre bom lembrar que cada um de nós é
único Ok quando falamos de alimentos
naturais O que funciona para um pode não
funcionar para outro se você tem alguma
condição específica ou se está em dúvida
sobre o que é melhor paraa sua saúde a
chave é observar o que você come fazer
um diário alimentar para observar os
sintomas e claro conversar com
profissional de saúde se você se sente
bem comendo aveia ótimo eu não tô aqui
para convencer ninguém a eliminar a veia
da sua vida da sua dieta o meu objetivo
é que você entenda os possíveis
inconvenientes ou problemas que são
individuais são particularidades de
pessoas e de outras não são sem ignorar
os seus benefícios para você a aveia
pode ser boa no contexto de uma dieta
equilibrada apenas prefira sempre aveia
em flocos ou mais integral ou mesmo
farelo de aveia Estes são melhores
opções do que a farinha de aveia faça os
métodos de deixar de molho em água ou a
fermentação e prefiro o equilíbrio e
moderação eu espero que essa conversa
tenha sido útil tenha esclarecido
algumas dúvidas e quem sabe te inspirado
a olhar a veia com outros olhos muito
obrigado pela sua atenção um grande
abraço um beijo no seu coração e você é
o quê você é
feira